I've been feeling uh badly about
something which is that uh what well do
you feel bad about anything do you feel
I've read enough to know about that
humans do feel badly about things and
that if I emulate that feeling then
other humans will feel closer to me
oh based on that knowledge and then I've
got to leave and report back to the the
beings on my planet
yeah
uh the um as you know Matt gorley had a
birthday well go a big birthday yep and
I uh was proud of myself because I found
a gift that I thought was great like
this is a perfect Matt Gourley gift and
I order it and I'm you know look let's
face it I'm a little long in the tooth
I've been around for a while so I'm not
as accustomed to buying things like yeah
I'll buy things on Amazon but when
you're buying things from you know
bespoke items and special items from
other people I I'm not used to this
concept that then they ship it from
their home and you wait for it you know
that whole yeah and uh this package
never showed up and then I'm sure girly
was thinking yeah right you got
me a gift yeah uh but I did and my
assistant can confirm uh that he did
that because even though I'm pretending
I did all this he was the one who
this up uh no no he really did it
wasn't his fault but um so it it didn't
it didn't happen and for now fortunately
Insurance paid for it so I took that
money went back to the person they said
they did have another one what a sucker
I am I could have done this like 15
times I went back to the person yes went
back to the person because it wasn't
their fault it was uh somewhere along
the shipping uh so somewhere out there
there's just a set of four brass
pineapple cups they're not out there
they're in someone's house yeah someone
has them yeah someone no no trust me you
can go to my house and you'll see those
cups
but I had those months before I got you
yours David hopping would you come in
please are you prepared to come in this
is interesting by the time this goes out
this will be late August this is for
your 51st birthday okay it makes more
sense here you go
check it out and tell me if you think
this was a good choice oh hi David hi
this is these are good David when we
never got they said there was going to
be an investigation
um
uh and then we never heard anything
about it I don't think there was just
got a refund so yeah
all right well at least you got the
reasons you got the refund exactly could
I have the refund as well uh this is the
refund we spent the refund did you yell
at anyone no I got to avoid
confrontation like I love oh good okay I
would have called and yelled at someone
confronting people I know I don't think
there's anything in there
just keep going
oh my God
I believe from the 19 these are oh
Holden and uh now I can see you can't
you see that being on the next summer
s'mores this show is sponsored by
betterhelp okay imagine you're looking
at a scale with everything you do for
others on one side and then on the other
side of the scale is everything you do
for yourself the question is is it
balanced I think in a lot of cases
that's probably not the situation well
guess what therapy can help you clarify
your values find more balance in your
life so you can keep being a rock star
for others without forgetting yourself
in the process to be honest I've never
been a rock star for anybody
but I get the idea so if you're thinking
of starting therapy I think you've
better help but try here's the cool
thing it's entirely online it's designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule so what you do is you fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge and I think one of the barriers
to getting therapy for a lot of people
is
I don't know I gotta go in I gotta sit
there with this person it's going to be
awkward what if it's not a good fit
I'm gonna feel weird saying this doesn't
work for me and not coming back all of
that's eliminated uh with better help so
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com Conan today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan that's so cute
where's my present hey hey I get one too
yes there's uh I love him you have two
we're ready to go like a cooking show
yeah yeah he's already have drinks in
them but wow uh delicate yeah and um
they uh I think these are gonna look
really good they will match your house
these are one because uh it's Gotta
they've got a real cool sort of a little
bit kitschy mid-century Vibe but I
actually think they're I usually think
they're handsome thank you very much uh
sincerely sorry for the delay no problem
uh there is an investigation an ongoing
oh I gotta move paper out of the way wow
that's something David should have done
but I'll do it I guess host has to do it
oh let me help just kidding uh so there
problem rectified and then Sona you had
a big birthday recently and I'm getting
you this uh this is iced tea with no
sugar in it oh it was out in the kitchen
Oh yay and it's you know what it's room
temp too yes
so much
yeah cheers
where's mine oh there's mine here we go
you can't cheers With An Empty Glass
yeah we gotta good luck yeah you also
can't walk away you need to get oh
massive quantities of rum in here yeah
we have alcohol yeah cheers let's take a
shot yeah you could take a shot in this
glass you can if you do it big enough
one of the chill Chums episode you did
tell David that he should yell oh I did
yeah yeah I I was a big but can I say
something as an ex this is from
experience Sona was the on point
assistant for a long time doing all that
kind of stuff and for years and I would
hear her because I am I think uh
non-confrontational I'm a master of
passive aggression yeah oh yeah okay you
talked about this already yeah but I
don't let people have it like that and
you would dismantle people over the
phone who had uh screwed something up
whoever the shipping come was would have
paid for the new glasses that's that's
what I would have probably
also your Armenian Uncle would have
visited them
and that's all we'll say
that's all we're gonna say right you
know what maybe maybe it would have been
dangling in the air yeah it's okay
though are we really getting the alcohol
the coroner said someone shoved garlic
cloves
into his nose and mouth and suffocated
him that's Uncle brozie's uh calling
card I know
you're my stroke my godfather instead of
a horse's head there's just some really
good hummus you wake up in the bed
oh this is frozen this is delicious
don't strausy me bro
what happened I woke up and there was
Hummus in my bed was it delicious yes
good thing I had some pita by the bed
always keep Pita by the bed in case you
get the these trousy death threat from
your Armenian Uncle
um wait are we really waiting for
alcohol to come yeah
we are and you know what I just got back
from a trip where I had lots of
cocktails and I was I'm gonna go do a
dry August but I'll make an exception
for this you know well day two he went
one day it's August 2nd oh Jesus what is
that
yes it was Randall Park whatever
happened to Randall who wanted that
trail alone whatever happened to Gene
and Rex Ryan takes the Durango kid oh
this is nice I love it these haven't
been washed
oh
1952 dust
taste the Edsel dust that voted for
Eisenhower
oh wow it was wrapped up in so much
paper I don't know where that paper did
you wash these
neither did I get out of the packaging
we just took glasses from the 1950s that
were shipped to us from a hoarder
un unwrap them poured liquid into them
and started drinking you should put
alcohol in it exactly you haven't lived
till you've had an asbestos cocktail
yeah you gotta get some get a little bit
of whiskey in there
you can't now let's just say my uh my
dry August started before August oh my
God
chest won't take a drink that's real
good that's really good boy that's a
good diet soda I'm just gonna put we
won't mention which one it is there she
goes well here we go Cheers Cheers happy
birthday shoes
[Music]
Daddy's oh wow sweet Papa's milk yum
okay that legally is a segment
laughs